in the last days of his life albert
einstein remained
vexed by a problem he had devoted so
much of his life to
how to reconcile his theory of general
relativity
with the emerging field of quantum
mechanics this problem
still blows cosmologist's mind even to
this day
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic general relativity
tells us how the presence of matter
curves
and warps space-time changing the
trajectories of massive objects like
planets
and altering the experience of time
itself
this theory our most successful in all
of physics
has given us the best descriptions of
large-scale motion
but as we shrink down to size scales
below the size of atoms we start to see
problems emerging some of the most
vexing problems come from the infinite
energies that emerge
at the infinitesimal short ranges at
subatomic scales
some emerge from how general relativity
changes the results of quantum mechanics
with the bending of space-time to
illustrate how this happens
imagine space-time as a flat trampoline
pulled
taut with massive objects on it
the objects viewed from above act in
very predictable
paths if we let the trampoline surface
change we start to see the objects
deflecting
rolling in ways we wouldn't normally
expect the surface
itself is deformed and the actors
the particles the massive planets
themselves are affected
the trampoline is still the same but its
shape
has changed we call this transformation
in terms of the shape of space
adiphiomorphism
and we call the invariance of it
diffumorphism and variance but the
objects are not
independent of the background they're on
trying to do quantum mechanics in a
dynamically changing spacetime
is like trying to draw a picture on a
piece of paper as it flutters in the
wind in an esoteric sense quantum
mechanical fields
can become self-interacting when the
background
itself is changing general relativity
describes space-time and how it deforms
quantum mechanics tells the story of the
objects
acting upon it our understanding of each
of them
independently is great but putting them
together
reveals fundamental disagreements some
of these disagreements are so
violent it's impossible to make any
prediction for many years theorists
tried to work with background dependent
models of the universe
but what if the background itself could
be redefined
in a way such that it gave us our
independence
diffiomorphism and variants back
ironically
this modern question is actually quite
ancient sometime around the 5th century
bce
greek and indian scholars proposed that
matter was not continuous
but gritty and indivisible at the
smallest level
the idea was championed by canada and
the greek
philosopher democritus
today we have robust evidence and models
of atoms and even subatomic particles
from the proton and neutron down to the
quark level
it's natural to wonder if a parallel
phenomenon exists for space and time
and space time itself if so there could
be a smallest
interval a smallest length and a
smallest time we call this process of
chopping up space into tiny pieces
quantization
exactly as we do with matter itself by
dividing up
or pixelating space time depending on
the dimension of the underlying space
itself
we see that space itself could be
quantized whether in one dimension
two dimensions three dimensions or any
arbitrary number of dimensions you would
choose
the secrets of chemistry were explained
with the quantization of matter
in the same way perhaps the secrets of
physics quantum mechanics
the subatomic scale could be explained
by quantizing
space-time if so it could remove the
infinities and unpredictable behavior
at the quantum scale that general
relativity introduces
as well as other issues in physics that
have gone unresolved
for almost a century establishing a
fundamental minimum distance scale
was the goal of early loop quantum
gravity physicists the first step was to
lay the groundwork of the theory
choosing an advantageous variable set
and finding new ways to describe the
universe theoretical physicist lee
smullin describes loop quantum gravity
as a theory of quantum spacetime based
only on experimentally well-conformed
principles
of general relativity and quantum
mechanics he notes four observations
that make up the backbone of the theory
the first
any theory using our understanding of
general relativity must be background
independent
second our idea of the background and
how it dynamically changes
should be consistently true when we
reach the very smallest world of quantum
mechanics
the last two observations are related to
how we use the field theories themselves
they're important for making sure there
is no universal proper time
coupled quantum fields that muddy the
math or extra dimensions that we don't
observe
together these observations inform the
quantized nature of space time
the earliest breakthroughs of the theory
involve special solutions
of the wheeler-dewitt field equation
fitted with astrocar variables
i know that's a mouthful but this is
where we get our loops
they're the solutions of a field theory
with these special variables
solutions of the wheeler to whit
equations allow you to describe quantum
phenomena with gravity present
the solutions are parallel transported
connections that describe curvature in
space-time
more abstractly properties of space-time
can be depicted as
functions on a space of loops this
stitch work pattern
can be the mathematical basis for the
nature of space-time
and quantum gravity springs from the
interaction of the loops themselves
from this point physicists like carlo
revelli spent several years trying to
tighten
up the mat in the mid 1990s constructs
of loops were chained together
creating something called a spin network
the spin network describes the geometry
of space
the loops and nodes move to represent
ticks of time
and when energy or mass is present
integration over the affected loops
gives us the properties of quantum
gravity that we're looking for
there are several benefits of loop
quantum gravity compared to other
theories of quantum gravity
we don't have to assume that physical
objects like strings or extra dimensions
exist
we don't have to prove the symmetries or
compactified dimensions
that string theory or other theories
introduce and we can still
solve the most important problems such
as describing the entropy
as formulated by the beckenstein hawking
formula without adding new assumptions
to the math
one last benefit is now there is a lower
limit on the length of the universe
which restricts the frequency of
electromagnetic waves
making infinitely high frequencies
impossible
so we're all done right loop quantum
gravity has so much promise
it must be the exact solution well it
has a lot of promise but it has some
glaring issues as well
it doesn't answer some questions about
what the masses of the elementary
particles are
it doesn't provide much insight on the
discrepancies
of quantum mechanics by itself for this
reason
it might only be the seed of a so-called
theory of everything
that has yet to fully sprout another
concern many physicists have with loop
quantum gravity
is that it makes predictions about the
velocity of photons being dependent on
frequency and perhaps even on the
polarization of photons
light from a very distant object called
a gamma-ray burst produces photons
say two of which come towards the earth
at the same moment by looking for slight
variations between the arrival time from
two different photons
with two different frequencies we can
test for the fundamental granularity of
space-time inherent in loop quantum
gravity
nasa's fermi gamma-ray space telescope
detected two photons from the same
source
nine tenths of a second apart in 2009
this experiment was a significant blow
to theories of loop quantum gravity
because over such a massive time scale
the photons traveled to the same speed
within one part in 100 million billion
it's possible that another experiment
one perhaps testing the polarization of
light instead
could reveal some evidence for loop
quantum gravity
for now many theorists find this
frequency discrepancy's failure to be
revealed
as a blow against loop quantum gravity
remember back when michiokaku
author of the god equation and a huge
proponent of string theory had this to
say about loop quantum gravity
well the problem is that gravity is
based on smooth surfaces
smooth elegant beautiful gorgeous
manifolds
well matter is based on chopped up
particles that you grind up and spit out
like a meat grinder it's all cut up and
so loop quantum gravity
which in which field does it fall into
it falls into the gravity field
but says nothing about electrons protons
quarks mesons the hundreds of scientists
the hundreds of particles that we have
analyzed
nothing about it it's a theory of pure
gravity
and therefore it is simply not a unified
field theory
which even the creators of the theory
acknowledge
they'd be the first ones to say that
their theory is not a rival
the string theory it's just an
alternative an alternative for
gravity but not for electrons protons
quarks you and me basically finding a
way
to merge general relativity in quantum
mechanics is still an urgent and
pressing matter to this very day
loop quantum gravity attempts to merge
them both in a background independent
way
and is therefore very virtuous if loop
quantum gravity can reconcile
the various lacuna that theoretical
physicists see in it
and pass fundamental physical tests in
observations of distant cosmological
objects
perhaps someday it could be found to be
not only a theory of quantum gravity
but maybe even a theory of everything
i'm brian keating
and this is into the impossible
[Music]
you